welcome back to 8701
in this short section we want to look at
the weak interaction a little bit more
and specifically discuss neutral
currents we looked
in some detail charge currents
specifically the interaction with quarks
so here
we want to look at the z border
specifically in the weak interaction
via the neutral current
so studying those two processes here
where there's an electron in the
positron
through some process including a z-boson
or a photon
resulting in a muon and an antimurr
those processes have been studied in
great detail at slack
and at cern with the slc and the large
electron position collider
so if we want to you know calculate the
cross section and
study the cross section of the center of
mass energy
we see a number of interesting effects
at low energies and at very large
energies
the cross section runs with one over the
energy squared
but at the mass of the z-border we see
this enormous resonance here so the
resonance is about 200
the cross-section at the resonance from
the z-border is about 200 times that of
just the photon exchange so this allows
you to study the z-boson
with great precision um at those
colliders you have
sizable cross-section when you're on
electron position colliders
and then you can with precision look at
you know what is the rate into
an antivirus what is the rate in the
quark antiqua and so on and you can
study the mass the width of the z
both on um with with an enormous
level of precision again so i will not
go into too much detail here um please
have a look at chapter
9.6 in griffiths for example but there's
many other resources where you can learn
about
more about neutral currents neutral
currents
electro weak neutral currents are
specifically important in the study of
neutrinos
as we have as we will discuss more in
the lectures as well